[Music]
all right in Harry baby news parents are
suing in fact we mixed up medications
leaving babies with abnormal body hair
like like like just like Chuck Norris
looking like little baby Bigfoot little
sasquatches yeah I want a chimpanzee
what no correlation as a pet there is
like a like a chimpanzee kid oh look
just a hairy kid or like oh no like not
an actual monkey as a child - - in range
look at Michael Jackson's bubbles yeah
like you don't want a chimpanzee and
overalls it's like the best in the world
aren't chimps hella strong and shake and
your arms often [ __ ] and that I didn't
want
I'm sorry friends Ross Marcel you guys
know what I'm talking about
yeah the parents in Spain are suing this
pharmaceutical company because they said
that there was a packaging mix-up or
Spanish health authorities are saying
that there's a packaging mix-up
involving a topical treatment and a
syrup so like this topical treatment is
for like hair growth so it's like giving
Rogaine to children exactly in the syrup
the syrup is for stomach problems
oh they mislabeled the medicine you've
got a stomachache but now it's furry as
[ __ ] yeah nice a hairless shitstorm the
stomach you guys see where the hair is
I'm gonna show you guys the video on our
growing hair on his chest
oh never mind I see that baby's gonna be
[ __ ] strong although Lisa works
I've never heard of y'all that's a furry
ass baby
I didn't sure they're not just Armenian
babies what does she got against hairy
babies anyways what do you mean she's
all like she's discriminating against
hairy babies hairy people that's what
she said getting at least 20 children
ranging from newborns to two-year-olds
have been affected simple wait one one
was a syrup and one was a topical so
does that mean that they they gave the
topical to the kid to ingest because you
wouldn't put a syrup on the skin yeah I
mean that's what I gather that's really
finesse that's what you should be sued
for you got me fungus swallowing desitin
yeah and it's supposed to be dimetapp
yeah what is this [ __ ] I want it for the
front of my head make something for the
front of your [ __ ] hair already have
you tried anything does it work
Oh kinds of [ __ ] or two Rogaine no it
hasn't worked look at me all kinds of
[ __ ] I like the Batman you got going
well thank you you're good man I do it
non-stop
I get obsessed well I heard that hair
technology today is like way [ __ ]
better than before before you have to
just spray some [ __ ] paint on that
[ __ ] vitamins or something do you know I
always see the thing for the ad for him
some you try hams they delivered to you
this door in the discrete packet no hate
to him I have tried it didn't work for
me works for some people didn't work for
that [ __ ] with your boy like a condom
what for what do you need him for
nothing they sailed everything you
evidently like vitamin I think
everyone's done a brand deal with the
hair stuff I don't know just whatever
man didn't work for me I'm sorry man
yeah I got the rough case hey you got a
lot of hair here that you could put up
peanuts a plan that's what this point
yeah I do surgery sumption yeah I'll
give you some of mine if I could just
have like black hair like right here you
know be funny too if it's like half his
hair and mine and it's like two
different colors your hair is awesome I
would take a strip of your black hair
that'll be a great icebreaker Blekko
what's going on with your head that's
weird story my brother-in-law he has one
of those strips of white because he had
like no melanin or whatever that is like
the Jay Leno nineties thing yeah that's
kind of cool I storm dr. strange all the
time no but you know um just last night
when I was looking up articles about
baldness right so they're saying I read
this article about Michael Jackson's
autopsy report and that they found that
he was like almost completely bald
really cause he had severe burns from
that the ATO just from that yeah I
thought it was like excessive use of
like the perm what I do know it was like
because he had like he was treated for
your second and third degree burns yeah
so there's like all these years he'd
been wearing and and his vitiligo thing
went really crazy yeah and I heard he
wasn't like nutrition well no I go yeah
yeah that's why he would famous cover
himself with the white makeup and all
that or whatever so it was just easier
to just do it one yeah you never saw
Michael Jackson in the short sleeve
shirt either mm-hmm thing about cover
from head to toe always in that Captain
Crunch jacket yeah I thought he did it
himself to go from black to light no but
that's the rumor because that you know
like yeah yeah and he had a lot of scars
like on his wrists his back of his neck
and like around his nostrils cuz there's
all like plastic surgery stuff wow
that's crazy
anyway okay we're talking about a hairy
baby do so now these families are going
to be suing they did close down that
pharmaceuticals yeah been shut down and
they're investigating but as of now
they're all these like carry babies but
they are saying that because of that
drugs ability to whiten widen blood
vessels it could impact the children's
hearts kidneys and livers and
future in a bad way is it reversible
because like now I assume they're not
taking any sales a regional are gonna be
strong like like testosterone or we know
how like we would when you have hair
he's supposed to have more testosterone
or whatever like I thought the babies
were gonna be like caveman babies and be
like really buff that will be scared ya
know they're saying that they did find
out or like the first concern about the
hairy babies were reported in April but
then authorities didn't recall the
medicine until July Oh families are like
what the [ __ ] our parents going to
consistently shave the babies are they
doing that no so they're saying that
eventually the extra hair will fall
oh because now they're not taking the
minute oh no no babies do come out
pretty hairy though Tiger came out with
all kinds of like crazy shoulder hair
and elbow hair and like but they the
doctors it was normal and then
eventually all those come off he's like
hairless together oh that's weird
[ __ ] they need here in the stomach for I
have no idea it's warm in there it's not
like as a freezer as a stomach these is
all the hormones from the mom and
finishes the crazy what happens is the
amniotic sac shut up sack of small coal
injector never heard of a sack before
zombie Mei has a doctor no but it is the
hormone stuff too because I remember
like with my son and my brothers like
when they were born their balls are huge
like they're really wrong yeah but then
they end up being normal cuz then like
that oh we grow into it stay the same
old already yeah pikas balls look like
the 25 yeah it already looks like a
abused elbow if you still like the
skateboarders elbow that's falling over
and over again this carnival those are
healthy balls huh Mazel Tov skaters
elbow
don't look at my elbows anymore comic
this is name is Esau McGraw he's like
y'all ever notice that the same skin
that's on your knee is the same skin
that's on your balls and the same skiing
that's on your elbow you could just line
them up like oh this is the elephant
skin on all three gotta protect the good
parts man Master do you guys lotion your
elbows no I don't know anything really
rough elbows I don't know
is it brush I'm pretty greasy so I turn
on it's okay I don't lotion anything huh
no cuz I remember in high school there
was this guy he had like the roughest
elbows ever let anything pass by
nothing's like [ __ ] alwah Wolverine
oh good my elbows get so right on Jake
it is cuz I'm sitting here like just the
whole day and then I lift him up it's
like it's nuts that looks really bad you
know get that checked out yeah I don't
think it's the desk you might need to
get some [ __ ] pads so you can wear
elbow pads in a helmet yeah elbow pads
for Jay King these days cuz I'm always
like this and my elbows hurt at the end
there's a page like the eighty suits you
know they got the look things they're
like they go on the best the keyboard is
why the [ __ ] professors always had
the leather suede [ __ ] over their
Blazers
man turned into a lion ah the other one
she was always a liar she's a woman
that's wrong they're born liars
have a history of it hey did you hear
about the first crime that was committed
in space it was by a woman yep so that
means a hundred percent of walls let's
not crime in space has been committed by
women yeah hold on they're still
investigating but that big fraud was
seems pretty guilty about no but she had
permission to enter that bank account
how much Steve on this one come on over
oh I just think women are space
criminals I believe her ex spouse and I
was like how we got them we got one and
I moved on did anyone read the details
the more you do that the more you
complicate it and you can't joke about
it later no cuz if you know too much you
can't joke about it yeah you know you
know the back story behind it right yeah
that's ignorant is man
exactly and that's why you play the
stereotypes and all kinds of [ __ ]
because everyone's gonna laugh more
likely to laugh at that then like let's
get into the details actually did you
know that this shooter actually happened
in the OJ case it's like oh my god you
don't believe in the moon more about it
what wait what are the facts there wait
hold on wait yeah what these balloons
fake hi okay so I think that I think
that Mars is real
I think the planets are real I think the
moon is horseshit wait a minute y'all
the let him stay on the show knowing
that he believes this you didn't say the
earth was flat I mean it might as well
it's [ __ ] Magellan
this is round actually so what do you
think that when when the tithe could
shift and everything from the move being
fool you think that this [ __ ] know
that that's not why the tides are
shifting his fancy cutter going to the
vacation because the fat people who are
going on vacations also jump down all
the water you almost had it you do that
cool I was really close I'm gonna help
people are gonna get mad at you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]